more battlefield 6 rumors are looking
pretty promising
and also what does the endgame of war
zone look like
i'm joined by aaron sampson and guys if
you are back for another week of these
chats
drop a like and subscribe if you haven't
already okay aaron what is the latest
with battlefield 6
ooh okay battlefield 6 rumor time um
again as always we're just going to
point out that these are rumors and
speculation at the moment and what we
love to do is just have fun
with those rumors and say like if they
were true this is kind of how we would
feel about them
so what's going on with battlefield
right now there's sort of two main
rumors swirling around
one of them from a you know slightly
reputable leaker that doesn't mean that
they're right
but what that person said was we're
gonna get a cinematic trailer now
and then we're probably not going to get
you know a demo or gameplay until
e3 this summer um during ea play live
if that's true you know again that'd be
a little disappointing if we just got
the cinematic trailer and then got the
gameplay later on
but that's actually pretty consistent
with how battlefields have been released
over the years
now what he's saying is actually in that
trailer sounds really interesting so
you know they've already been a lot a
lot of talk about the game being near
future
um about about ten years from now and
they
you know the tweets added a little bit
more flavor to that um and fans got in
there and did mock-ups so
we're we're looking at ospreys we're
looking at boston dynamic
robots um drones and other kind of near
future tech
which uh you know richie and i when we
were looking over the stuff we
immediately started laughing
if you keep kicking the robots boston
dynamics like this is what you get
we're gonna get robots and they're gonna
have enough of us humans
then the humans are going to be dead
they will remember every
every kick that you give them so don't
do that i hate those videos i hate those
videos
but hey like you know maybe this is the
chance for murder robots to get their
revenge
um okay so like let's let's talk about a
couple of things individually really
quick
as you know as an old battlefield fan
ospreys
super cool they're like the combination
um helicopter aircraft
so they would probably let you fare
troops across the field which gives
support players and helicopter fans
something new and fun to do
basically get players across the map
quickly and drop them off boston
dynamics robots are awesome i really
missed the eod robot
i missed the mav um which was a little a
little flying surveillance drone that
like we learned six months later could
also destroy equipment it's
it's that sandbox that a lot of
battlefield players really miss
like discovering things that you didn't
know you could do
and it just feels like battlefield's
been missing that for a while now though
like
watching a video and being like holy
hell i i didn't even know you could do
that right
so if we're going to drones we're going
to equipment we're going near future
um but not too not too crazy in the
future
that is a a net positive so sort of in
summary
like near future bringing that sandbox
back would be amazing
a little disappointing if we only get
like a cinematic trailer
and then we have to wait until you know
later in the summer to actually get our
hands on
they've said a bunch of times the game's
way ahead of schedule so i hope that's
wrong and i hope they have a demo
that'll come out sooner
but that's fairly consistent with how
they've released battlefields in the
past
all your talk about this equipment
reminds me of modern warfare 2019 and
all these myth busting videos like there
were more than ever for that game
because i kind of felt the same way like
there was all this there was so much
tech
and it's like oh i didn't know you can
do that with this you know
with xyz and uh that's a good feeling
so speaking of call of duty um warzone
is getting more and more ridiculous over
time and we're now looking at a war zone
that is going to do
the zombie event coming up very soon on
the 21st
but also now in the future gonna have to
smash in world war ii games and whatever
else is gonna happen
which kind of begs the question richie
where is
warzone going in the future it's
it's tough to say right now because
you're right like little by little
things are getting crazy and that's
usually
the way that games go like in the yearly
cycle the second half or more it gets
crazy but with warzone it's it's sort of
a different experience like this is a uh
more of a service game that's going to
stick around for a while and it's going
to incorporate more and more games
there's already two games and a million
guns and a bunch of funny skins
so they got me thinking about how it's
it's sort of
like call of duty online and call of
duty mobile
it's just sort of a crapshoot of all
these games and it's not really a bad
thing aaron you know how much i talk
about
call of duty mobile to you and how like
it's it's
i want to say it's slept on but it's not
like millions of people are playing so
if you play
like let me know in the comments because
i'm generally curious i don't know if
it's just
children because it's for free and they
have access to an ipad but
i play every now and then and i always
have a lot of fun it's it's goofy like
it's goofy in its marketing and it's way
goofier and it's like
customization and skins and it's doing
things that
any other call of duty game has never
done same kind of goes for
call of duty online it's like the older
brother to that like it's a mishmash of
maps throughout every call of duty guns
throughout every call of duty
it's not available in the north american
region so i've only seen gameplay
and it looks i'm jealous because there
are a bunch of maps i want to play and
stuff like that the closest thing we can
get to
is call of duty mobile and it's fun so i
first of all i suggest you play it
and second of all i'm kind of thinking
like long term this whole mishmash
style of of games across the decades
can be something that warzone can get to
if i'm if i'm thinking really wild about
it but it doesn't sound that too out of
the question it's already kind of
like that in some ways like the seeds
have been planted to go a little crazy
here
whether or not people will stay for
however long is the question
but then again uh you know call of duty
mobile does
millions aaron what was it billions of
dollars in micro transactions like
the parent company made something around
10 billion dollars
um that's not just on call of duty
mobile but it's it's it's a chunk of it
and uh
if that's not getting activision's
attention i'm not sure what
what would exactly but i i so i guess
the question is like now that cold war
is adding in dragon guns and samurai
swords and people in yellow
kill bill outfits like do we want
warzone
to get that silly i mean you said it's
good like you said
call of duty mobile is actually quite
good it's just a it's a different
environment and it's easy
to access like i played with my iphone
and a ps4 controller like that's it and
it's free
um so i definitely see like the future
of
of warzone i you know i'm not hopeful
but i'm curious if it could get there
we're just gonna have to see how that
goes down the line it's too early to
call
so that's how we're thinking warzone
might end up but what is the state of
war zone right now
aaron what's going on what's the latest
yeah so
people don't have much longer to wait um
this zombie
event on the map has been happening very
very slowly
um not being communicated the best but
we finally have a clear end date that's
the 21st
and we know things are going to happen
at the dam based on tweets and um
paraphernalia that treyarch loves to
send out to their youtubers
um that's consistent with a splash
screen too which was a picture of the
dam
so the real question is you know what
are they gonna do how are we gonna get
back to the
1980s map with zombies um and
how much are the nukes actually going to
tie into this but overall this season
has just felt like a lot of stalling the
zombies haven't been very exciting
and it's time to get this thing moving
so we're glad and and it's gonna happen
now
hopefully it'll be fun hopefully it'll
be as good as haunting it for dance
i'm looking for that limited time mode
kind of vibe too because that was so fun
last time they did it so i know they're
capable of doing it but you're right
about
all the stalling and i've been playing a
little more war zone lately and i
i've seen those missiles kind of just
coast by and
you know that video of that one landing
which is kind of like
doesn't do anything on impact uh so it's
a little underwhelming
i'm still having fun with the core game
which is important but
let's you know let's go we got the we
got the date we'll be there
where i'm at right now in warzone is
i've decided i wanted to show up the
cold war kids even though they have the
better weapons
um so i've decided to do a couple rounds
as like
all all modern warfare as savage looking
as i can with modern warfare guns
and i actually won one last night so i
was pretty excited about that
um but yeah just i'll be here
representing for the modern warfare
2019 crowd um but that's not to say the
cold war
people don't deserve the best and i we
hope that you guys are really enjoying
the game also
assuming that some of these balance
changes finally happened that i think
pretty much
all the fans have been asking for um the
meta the meta needs to change a bit away
from a couple of
high-powered weapons yeah the meta is in
sort of a weird place it's a little more
streamlined than before but hopefully
just gets better and better
uh but speaking of the meta raven raven
software announced a bunch of more bands
i think they're at a total of like
near 500 000 bands which is good
and like i you know i want to be
positive about that because it is good
they're doing
they're not doing nothing but the thing
is i just hope more of these accounts
don't keep sprouting up we're still
seeing hackers i mean
i would say less in my sort of lobbies
which are you know
mid-skill level players but also um we
had another
sort of accidental band problem with
zombies players on pc i don't know
if you all have heard but uh players on
pc
are getting to high rounds of zombies
kind of like normal
but when they do they're getting this
weird error and they're not just getting
kicked out of a game but they're
getting account bans like it's pretty
unfortunate
and i don't know if they're doing
anything about it but it doesn't seem to
be
that common but common enough like
there's a reddit thread going around
with like
more and more people talking about it
every day so it's unfortunate hopefully
something can be done because your
reward for getting to like round 50 of
zombies should not be getting
an account then and that's sucks to see
you're just too good at killing zombies
be less good at killing the undead i
mean come on
yeah save some for us also in some more
unfortunate news
it looks like vanguard's production
might be a little rocky right now
aaron what do you know i mean it's
plausible
um you know sledgehammer who is supposed
to be the studio that's now
developing vanguard um people
you know they were theorizing that
sledgehammer is probably behind right
now because
they've been sort of um shuffled between
studios for a couple different games now
paradox here said vanguard is allegedly
just hanging on by a thread
and if true battlefield is taking no
prisoners
so yeah the development cycle for cold
war was obviously a mess with multiple
studios being taken on and off of those
one of those studios being sledgehammer
who you know it would kind of make sense
after being pulled off cold war and then
asked to make vanguard within
a very short span of time means that
it's one of the shorter development
cycles that they've ever had for a call
of duty game
and that means there's potential if
that's true to get another rush call of
duty game
i'm not sure if call of duty fans can
take another rush call of duty game
cold war was definitely had had issues
had issues at launch and just sort of
generally felt like a step back
um in many ways than modern warfare
particularly in just like visuals and
animations um
you know a lot of the a lot of the
movement mechanics in the shooting
was intentionally made the way it is in
a more classic call of duty style
and i don't want to take away from that
because that was intentional that's the
way that
um classic call of duty players love it
and and they are enjoying that
but things like animations armor doors
and things like that
felt very rushed and added in later to
kind of bring it in line with modern
warfare and
you know they don't really quite work as
well as modern warfare
i don't know man like i don't i don't
know if the call of duty crowd can take
another hit like that
but we'll just have to see you know and
with that let's move on to some good
news
and your comments first some good news
from infinity ward which we haven't
heard from in a while
they came out and explained why the
three new maps were
were launched quietly and then taken
down two of them i believe were taken
down
so infinity ward just explained that
they needed a little more love
a little more work but they'll be back
so this is great news
any support for modern warfare is good
support moving on to some of your
comments by the way
keep leaving them we love reading them
and we love featuring them in these
episodes
last week we asked you guys how you
wanted the map to transition back to the
80s and the
best response was by jfro who said all
the vehicles in dansky turn into
deloreans
and you and the boys gotta hit 88 at the
airfield
yes i almost get it i hope to let you
finish that because i was
just laughing here uh yeah that would be
great
that would never happen pretty much any
other way it's gonna happen now is going
to be less cool than that idea so thank
you you've now ruined the zombies event
for us
jfro set the bar too high with this one
but we'd love to see it this is some
gta right here whoa this is heavy our
next comment from rick here
says i don't think they'll associate war
zone with this next release
and that it'll carry on independently
this was something
that i found pretty interesting because
it's probably it might be true if it's a
world war
ii thing i don't know how or
if warzone will be able to back it
or you know incorporate it into anything
really
aaron what do you think you know i'll
have to fall back on what i know which
is battlefield
um bad company 2 you know made these
veteran weapons where they brought world
war ii guns in as
as like prestige weapons like the m1
garand and a couple other guns
it can be done um the problem is that
those guns don't have mods
and i don't know how you handle that
um the battlefield series didn't handle
that very well
you know going the last the last two
battlefield games had like very
confusing modding systems or just
nonsensical
modding systems for world war ii guns so
that's a decent point like it would be
hard
to bring world war two weapons into
warzone
that being said it just really feels
like
war zone is gonna be the tie-in for all
call of duty games moving forward
there's not great options for world war
two guns to be in a modern shooter
but there are workarounds if you're
willing to be silly enough
be sure to tune in next week you guys
because we are finally gonna figure out
what is going on on the 21st if you like
the video drop a thumb
and we'll see you next time drop a thumb
oh god
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you